you mentioned
the issue of fake crowd noise yeah i
caught wind of this one yesterday now i
asked the league what are your plans for
fake crowd noise official response from
the league the plans are still being
finalized here's what they're
considering and if you were watching
closely earlier you saw it up and there
it is it's back well it's coming back
it'll come back just it'll magically
magically reappear there it is look at
that boy if if only i had that power in
other kinds of gods
the nfl is considering
fake crowd noise in the range of 70 to
85 decibels and here's the kicker chris
it would be the same
the entire game
whether the home team is on offense
or the road team is on offense
think about how messed up that is
potentially
for a team like the vikings right for a
team like the vikings that is going to
be able to operate in relative quiet
when they have the ball at home in their
stadium and then when the other team has
the ball it gets loud we we posted a
photo last night from a vikings game
where on the video board it showed the
decibel level at 118.3
when the denver broncos were in the
huddle that game last year when the
vikings were down what was it 20 to
nothing at halftime and they came back
and won the game right so uh yeah it
makes no sense
to make it the same and it works that in
and of itself works as a disadvantage to
the teams that have a great home field
advantage yes it does it gets it's out
the window definitely you know
especially the team that has the home
field advantage and then also has a high
octane offense where let's say the new
orleans saints it's loud as hell when
the defense is there you can't hear a
guy three inches from your face
but those fans are smart and then they
know when drew brees is on the field hey
everybody shut the hell up he's got to
audible and make calls and talk to sean
payton and get everybody on the same
page like that doesn't make sense to me
why
what is the logic behind doing that we
can't have a guy in the audio booth go
okay
my team's on defense here we're gonna
put it at 85 decibels wait now my team's
on offense the nfl has mandated that i
put it at 35 decibels because it's quiet
you know just ambient noise whatever it
may be i don't understand the hard line
of that
i agree with you if you're going to do
it the right way to do it in the fair
way to do it and i assume
that that somewhere somehow if they
don't have this they should some sort of
information about what the average
decibel level is
for let's say the vikings when they're
playing at home when they have the ball
the average decibel level when the
defense has the ball and yes it's going
to change right one of the one of the
objectives of a visiting team when they
go and play in a loud raucous stadium is
what chris take the crowd out of the
game exactly now that's when it gets
even more complicated because well
ordinarily it would be 100 decibels when
the opposing team has the ball but you
know they're kicking the crap out of us
right now i almost said a different word
there and it wouldn't be very loud right
now the the fans would have given up
they would have left by now so that's
where it gets a little complicated but
it's still better to factor in what it
normally sounds like in a normal year
right than to just say we're going to
have this set level that's always going
to why why just why have anything have
nothing then it makes no sense to have
background noise that's going to be the
same regardless of who has them no i i
don't like that i don't get it and it's
very easily fixed so i i mean i just
would like to know the logic behind just
keeping it there i don't i don't i don't
get that and i would think that would
make some teams you know annoyed to a
degree yeah who who look forward to
playing home and having those advantages
and being able to you know yell a word
and not have to give signals or yell a
new word for the week and not have to
show a team the signal all those type of
things uh so yeah i i don't get that one
i hope that gets fixed
and this is something you need to factor
into
your
if if you are so inclined to do so in a
jurisdiction where it's legal your
wagering selections week by week and big
picture division winners playoff teams
because here's who benefits from this
chris the chargers benefit from this the
falcons benefit from this you know the
falcons stadium they've had like 43
million in defaults on their psl yeah
that stadium has quietly been overrun by
fans of popular teams that come into
play right the chargers we know there's
nothing quiet about it it's laughable
the way that the soccer stadium they
were playing in was being overrun last
december the vikings played there it
looked like a vikings home game at the
at the outdoor stadium they played at
for three years while their new stadium
was being built that's how many vikings
fans were there so for teams like that
that don't truly have a home field
advantage because so many fans of the
opposing team show up and so few of
their fans do
they they have an easier time at home
now and they go on the road if you play
a team that has a true home field
advantage that's wiped out those are the
teams to watch the teams that have not
had a home field advantage yeah that
that that basic you know the chargers in
2018 the year that they had that 12-4
record they didn't lose outside of los
angeles until the divisional round
against the patriots that's they were
they were battle hardened look you if
you don't if you have a bunch of fans
who are rooting for the visiting team
when you play at home going on the road
is a picnic and so that that franchise
has had that baked in it's going to be
great for them this chargers team
they're going to have the lack of a home
field disadvantage and they're going to
be facing teams that don't have a home
field advantage that plays right into
their cards for this season well what
you know at what point are they going to
let nfl teams know what's going to be
you know the protocol here too you know
finalizing plans yeah finalizing plans
15 days to go yeah well that's that's
what i mean because we're getting down
to like you said 15 days to go
right and a few extra days for the rest
of the league but 15 for the texans and
the chiefs to where
you know you might want to start
practicing with crowd noise to be
prepared for your first game you know
hey desean watson yeah we're going to
kansas city hey the nfl mandated they're
going to put it at 85 decibels hey guys
yeah we can start have some practices
with uh some speakers out here what do
you want to say what you've tripped
you've tripped on to an open question
because the chiefs are going to have
fans present one thing that i've asked
and haven't gotten an answer to yet from
sources per sources right will they
still use that that minimum decibel
level if you have 15 000 fans there or
will they abandon the fake noise in any
game where fans are allowed to be
present regardless of the noise that
they're going to create oh i wonder that
too that's why i was bringing it up
before about the cowboys and being that
spread out is that really going to be
even loud enough to get to a mark to
where they might still go hey fans are
here but this is not that loud we're
going to turn up the volume and have
some fake noise too but yeah i mean
i would think you'd want to know those
type of things preparing for a game
first game of the year you know first
live bullets action here we go
yeah this is the time where coaches
start to infuse hey bring the speakers
out to practice make it loud desean
you're gonna have to speak up in the
huddle guys you have to start reading
lips and you know getting used to that
and silent count at the line of
scrimmage and signals and all that uh so
they're getting dangerously close to
where they got to start to let these
teams know so they can prepare
and here's the other thing too right we
talked earlier about whether it's worth
it financially to have a partial crowd
in your stadium but if
they will turn off the fake noise if you
have fans present oh that's a reason to
have fans present because
you don't have to deal with the 70-85
decibels while you're trying to run your
offense who who cares how loud it gets
when the road team has the ball
it's not going to be loud when you have
the ball you're not going to have to
deal with that that ambient 70 to 85
decibels every time you're out there
trying to make your offense go so that's
a that falls that's another crows
category
if regardless of whether or not you care
about the extra two million dollars that
you're gonna make by having a full
season of partial crowd that's a reason
to want to have a partial crowd if they
turn off that machine well yeah yeah but
you know that's where i mean if you have
a great defense you might not like that
if you're one of those teams that's
trying to be built through that to where
oh okay now we have crowd in the stands
and what we can't use the speaker volume
uh and it's not that loud there's only
15 000 people here they might as well
not have any noise or anything like that
it's not affecting the other team you
know they might not like that aspect of
it either so yeah they need to figure
that out are they going to have noise
with the stadiums that are a quarter
full or half full or whatever it is is
there going to be other extra noise and
then of course what is it going to be
set at and the fact that they're talking
about just 75 to 85 the whole game no
matter who's on offense or who's on
defense that makes no sense i don't get
that so
i i would hope that the nfl would would
fix these situations here soon
yeah i think the easiest thing to do is
just have no supplemental crowd noise
that's just one less opportunity for
shenanigans and it just doesn't make
sense and let the crowd noise be added
into the broadcast like we've seen with
other sports
doesn't sound bad it doesn't sound
unnatural it only gets weird when you
hear crowd noise and you have a shot of
this
sea of empty seats yeah because that's
when you realize that crowd noise is not
coming from the fans who aren't there so
that's where it all stands and this is
an important issue because we are 15
days away and we know it's a deadline
driven business but this isn't the kind
of issue that should be left until the
11th hour this is something that at the
very latest at the absolute latest and
here's hoping they have it done by then
before teams begin their preparations in
earnest for week one and for the chiefs
and the texans that's a week from
tomorrow as a practical yeah i would
even say a little bit of that yeah let's
make sure everyone knows what the rules
are i mean the clock is ticking very
loudly somewhere in the range of 70 to
85 decibels
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports